der schach krimi von saint-louis
schachweltmeister magnus carlsen er
verliert gegen einen 19-jährigen der
allerdings soll dabei geschummelt haben
das gene vor laufenden kameras alle
augen sind natürlich auf dieses spiel
auf die spieler gerichtet alles live
übertragen und dazu dazu gibt es jetzt
eine interessante theorie die sogar
ideen musk lachend per twitter
verbreitet
[Musik]
diese vorwürfe versetzen die sonst so
gesittete schachwelt in helle aufregung
angestoßen hat sie der beste
schachspieler auf dem globus weltmeister
magnus carlsen
am sonntag sorgt der norweger für einen
paukenschlag nach seiner niederlage
gegen den amerikaner hans niemanden beim
sync hielt cup in st louis zog sich
carlsen vorzeitig vom turnier zurück in
seiner gesamten karriere hatte er das
noch nie getan schuld daran sollen man
kann es kaum glauben anal perlen sein
aber der reihe nach
seinem abgang lässt kassen einen
nebulösen tweet folgen der die
gerüchteküche zum brodeln bringt carlsen
schreibt ich habe mich vom turnier
zurückgezogen ich habe es immer genossen
beim sein blues jazz club zu spielen und
hoffe irgendwann noch einmal
zurückzukehren pikant seinen tweet
garniert kreisen mit einem
videoausschnitt eines alten interviews
mit fußball trainer jose mourinho damals
trainer des fc chelsea
ich ziehe es vor nicht zu sprechen wenn
ich spreche bin ich in großen
schwierigkeiten
was will kassen mit seinem tweet
andeuten für die schach community ist
die sache klar carlsen unterstellt
seinem gegner betrug beißt sich aber
öffentlich auf die zunge wohl auch weil
er bisher keine beweise hat
andere stars sind jedoch weniger
zimperlich der erfolgreichste schach
streamer und mehrfache us champion
recaro nakamura zurück weiter
ich weise darauf hin dass niemand in der
vergangenheit bereits zweimal wegen
betruges gesperrt worden ist
den heftigsten vor aber packen die
kanadischen großmeister erik hansen und
erman hamilton aus sie mutmaßen in einem
tweet livestream wie man habe
möglicherweise manipulierte anal perlen
verwendet die ihm mit entsprechenden
signalen vom computer errechnete
spielzüge anzahl sollte bitte was ließ
sich niemand etwa wirklich mit rektalen
morsey codes zum sieg gegen den
schachweltmeister brummen und wie soll
das überhaupt gehen die unfassbare
theorie der schacht konkurrenten niemand
könnte sich eines der sex toys
eingeführt haben und möglicherweise von
einem helfer vibrationen per
fernsteuerung empfangen haben eine idee
die so absurd ist dass sie natürlich
auch des labors elon musk gefällt der
witzelt bei twitter gestaltet eine
weisheit des philosophen arthur
schopenhauer das talent trifft ein ziel
dass kein anderer tritt das chemie
trifft ein ziel dass kein anderer sieht
macht ergänzte in klammern dahinter weil
es in deinem allerwertesten steckt die
vorwürfe sind so abenteuerlich dass sie
kaum zu glauben sind doch dazu dürfte es
unmöglich sein sie nachzuweisen dennoch
sieht sich niemand genötigt zu reagieren
außer einmal mit zwölf jahren habe ich
nie nie nie bei einem offiziellen
turnier mit preisgeld betrogen im
größten schach seit mehreren jahren
holte er dann zum gegenschlag aus und
wird carlsen und anderen topspielern vor
seine karriere zerstören zu wollen sein
angebot
ich komme gerne zum spiel und ziemlich
komplett aus was auch immer er für einen
fairplay check machen wollt es ist mir
egal weil ich sauber bin ich
eine antwort des weltranglisten-ersten
magnus carlsen steht noch aus
das wäre geschafft und man dachte bisher
immer mehr so gut spielt der muss wie
ein bisschen friedlich unterwegs sein
die geschichte hat sich jetzt nicht
außer kraft gesetzt werde sich aber
hatte zeigt wie spannend schach ist
[Musik]